Pennywise is back to start a new cycle
of horror that brings the lose at home
in an effort to defeat it for good
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video we're diving deep below
dairy to discuss the ending of it
chapter two the fate of the losers and
the evil clown and the secret michurin
turtle Easter egg in the ritual of chugs
that everyone missed keep watching for
details about a special Pennywise
giveaway and of course spoilers ahead
when the young losers defeated Pennywise
at the end of the first movie it went
into hibernation underground however its
influence over dairy remains strong 27
years later dairy feels a lot more
hopeless as if the town's making its
last dying gasp
before fully succumbing to it says
screenwriter Gary Doberman and this is
brutally evident early on when a group
of thugs beat up Adrian melon in a
vicious hate crime throwing him into the
river this signals the return of
Pennywise who then feeds on the injured
Adrian scrawling bloody messages has
always been part of its MO but now the
killer Klown no longer does that to
scare away the losers instead he uses
gory missives to get them to return home
after waiting and planning vengeance
Pennywise is desperate to do away with
the losers for good and pay them back
for foiling its plans during the
previous cycle leaving it hungry now
you're the one who's afraid because
you're gonna starve over time it has
become more cunning more sophisticated
in manipulation and therefore deadlier
as we see in chapter 2 during the scene
with young Victoria which director Andy
machete uses a mirror scene of what
happened with Georgie are you crying
anymore
they okay with me would you come free
for active bill skarsgård present-day
penny wise has a strange bond with the
losers because although he instills fear
in humans
he'd never understood what that was
until the losers and then he felt it for
himself because most of the losers left
town they gradually forgot the events
they went through in Derry but despite
their geographical distance from it and
the fact they've repressed many of the
terrors they enjoyed as children
including the abuse bullying bigotry
death of a sibling and endless
insecurities their past still casts a
heavy shadow over their present bill
can't find closure in his writing all
real happiness with the wife who isn't
the woman he wants her to be
Bev's gone from living with an abusive
father to an abusive husband and Eddie
hasn't been able to throw off the
shackles of an overbearing parent and is
married to Myra a woman who is much like
his mother
and fun fact Eddie's wife Myra is played
by the same actress Molly Atkinson who
played his mother in the first movie the
wounds left by it may not be as fresh as
they were 27 years ago but the trauma
the young losses experienced then still
marks their everyday lives
in unconscious ways and has brought
painfully to the surface when they get a
call from Mike the only one who stayed
in town and never forgot Pennywise each
member of the childhood Club suffers a
traumatic reaction to Mike's call with
Bill for example suddenly feeling pain
in his hand from the blood oath he made
with the others as a child out of those
who left stan has the most harrowing
reaction and I'll discuss that together
with his letter to the others later in
the video
the losers Chinese restaurant reunion
brings memories of Pennywise flooding
back and they're freaky fortune cookie
hallucinations caused a rift in the
group Mike however manages to persuade
bill to go back to the library where
Mike reveals he's been investigating the
history of Pennywise and how it came to
dairy in the first place Mike shows bill
an 18th century Native American
artifacts that belonged to a group of
holy men that lived outside Derry and
who were beyond the range of its
influence Mike secretly spikes bills
water with a route which allows bill to
see a vision of its arrival on earth via
a meteor that crashed underground in the
spot where Derry
later built bill sees its original form
the dead lights emerge from the cave and
float up to the surface where they
reform into a bird then shape-shift into
various monstrous creatures with mouths
full of teeth to devour the people in
its path a crucial detail that Mike also
learns from the Native Americans is a
rule that all living things must abide
by the laws of the shapes they inhabit
this is critical later for the final
showdown as it means it can be killed
for good if it transforms into something
weak and vulnerable enough there's also
a very cool Easter egg in this scene
which is a twist on the cosmic turtle
from Stephen King's original novel when
Mike calls the route the Native American
tribe gave him their sacred Mattern it's
an interesting detail that's very hard
to catch as mike says the name quite
quickly and the mention of mutterings
name seems to indicate that the cosmic
turtle is trying to help the losers by
revealing its weaknesses there's a few
other turtle Easter eggs in the first
movie and in Chapter 2 a turtle also
shows up on a desk when Ben revisits an
old classroom and when the camera turns
in that scene it looks as if a globe of
the earth is sitting on the turtle's
back which is pretty appropriate because
for those who don't know michurin is a
benevolent interdimensional entity from
King's Mac reverse that created the
universe by vomiting as her the scene
also introduces us to the ritual of
chert which the original natives of the
area learned as a technique to attempt
to contain and even destroy it we see
them standing around a four-sided
pyramid container which works to trap
the dead lights that container is the
artifact that mike has in his possession
and he explains to the losers that the
ritual requires they each sacrifice a
token from their childhoods and burn it
in the container to collect their tokens
each loser spends the day reliving old
memories and confronting past Horrors
for Bev this means returning to her
childhood home where she retrieves the
postcard with the poem Ben Center your
hair is
January hammers and she also encounters
mrs. Kirsh transforming into a giant
grotesque witch and an apparition of a
man turning into Pennywise bill recovers
the paper boat from the drain where his
little brother was taken as a child and
is reminded of the guilt he's been
hiding about the day Georgie died
Richie's token is a coin from the arcade
where I used to play games as a kid and
were in a flashback we discover he was
bullied by Henry Bowers and his cousin
who called him gay Ritchie ends up back
in the park by the Paul Bunyan statue
which Pennywise brings to life to attack
him when he taunts him about hiding his
sexuality
Eddie's token is his inhaler where he
meets the creepy old pharmacist again
and a now grown-up Greta
he also has a horrifying encounter with
a leather monster like the one that
attacked him as a child outside the
niebolt house in the first movie Ben's
token is the yearbook page that Bev
signed for him in Chapter one and Mike's
is the rock that Bev threw at Henry
Bowers to save him from the bully the
losers also includes Stan in the ritual
by adding one of the shower caps he
bought for the losers to use in their
Clubhouse
in order to keep their hair free of
spiders which feels like foreshadowing
of their climactic battle with it the
losers then commence the main part of
the ritual by burning the tokens and
chanting the phrase turn light into dark
this summons the dead lights into the
artifact
however the container immediately swells
up with a huge red balloon which fills
the space until it bursts revealing
Pennywise the clown taunts them that
their silly ritual will never work as
when the Native Americans tried it they
all died
Pennywise then reveals that Mike knew
that all along and hid the truth from
the others by scratching out the
artifacts drawing of the dead lights
killing the tribe Mike explains the
mistake the Native America's made was
that they didn't believe they could
defeat it but Pennywise starts attacking
the losers and once again they're split
up and sent off to enjoy a psychic
battle of wills with it who confronts
each one with some of their personal
fears Beverly is thrown back into the
school bathroom stall whereas a kid she
was bullied by Greta and other girls who
poured watery trash all over her
time the store fills with blood evoking
the blood-soaked bathroom scene from the
first movie as the store fills that is
tormented by various abusers banging on
the door including her violent husband
her abusive father the sleazy mr. Keene
and her childhood bullies and Henry
Bowers even shows up for a quick here's
Johnny easter-egg from The Shining in
the meantime been has been flung into
the underground club house he built as a
child as it fills with dirt Pennywise
traps him inside and taunts him that
he'll die alone this is torture for Ben
because as we learn early on in chapter
2 he's been something of a loner since
his looser days and he's extremely
claustrophobic living alone in a house
full of floor-to-ceiling windows so he
can always see plenty of space around
him and in that scene we also saw the
adult been advising his firm's clients
to stop putting more walls into a new
retail building that they were designing
when we cut back to Beverly she's almost
drowning in blood and being tormented by
her father yelling and asking if she's
still his little girl Bev eventually
overcomes the shackles of guilt and
shame her father imposed on her and
kicks the door in his face finally
rejecting him and the violence against
her that he represented when Ben calls
out that he loves her they're both able
to break through their ilusory prisons
and reach out to each other this time
it's bear view pulls Ben out from the
dirt which is swallowing him up saving
him in a reversal of the first movie
where he pulled her out of the dead
lights trunks for Bill his test is to
face a vision of his dead brother
Georgie in the flooded basement of his
childhood home at this point Georgie
reveals that Bill wasn't really sick and
blames his older brother for his fate
[Music]
bill manages to overcome the guilt and
blame that Pennywise is trying to
project onto him and he shoots the
younger version of himself in the head
with a cattle bolt gun in a callback to
how he shot Pennywise masquerading as
Georgie in the first movie the other
losers personal tests aren't as intense
with Eddy and Richie going up against
the scary doors Ritchie opens the very
scary door only to find Betty rip sans
mutilated legs running up to him which
harks back to the first movie when he
discovered Betty's shoe in the sewer and
it's also a nod to the not scary at all
door that Ritchie opened with Bill and
the niebolt house where they found the
upper half of Betty rip sans mutilated
body where's my shoe behind Eddy's door
is a cute Pomeranian dog which turns
into a huge monster and Easter Egg to
the dog transformation scene from the
thing as for Mike he doesn't really seem
to have a personal test or it might have
been cut for time from the final movie
after these various battles of wills the
losers then go up against it who's now
turned into a horrific Lovecraftian type
Pennywise spider or crab hybrid Ritchie
runs up to the monster but it traps him
in the dead lights just like Pennywise
did with young Beverly in the first film
Eddie sees Ritchie trapped and summons
up the courage he previously couldn't
muster when Ritchie was being attacked
by the stand spider monster in the
niebolt house which is another easter
egg to the thing now Eddy takes a metal
railing spike that Beverly gives him and
which he also used to attack Pennywise
in Chapter one and he remembers what she
told him
take it because monsters simply because
Eddie finally overcomes his fear and
self-doubt throwing the spear into its
mouth causing the giant spider clan to
fall back on the huge spikes in the
cavern severely injuring the creature
it's heartbreaking when Eddie believes
he's finally triumphed over the monster
only for it to stab him through the
chest mortally wounding him before he
dies though Eddie tells the losers how
he almost killed the leper in the
pharmacy basement how when he choked it
he made the monster small and feel so
weak the other losers then realized
their only hope of killing the giant
Pennywise spider is to make it much
smaller and therefore
weaker with this the losers make their
final stand against Pennywise like
real-life bullies many of penny wisest
tactics employ fear and intimidation to
make its victims feel weak
so the losers turn the tables on it
calling it names a stupid clown a
headless boy and impostor a mimic a
bully a stupid mummy and so on as they
do this the losers imprint their will on
the monster and shrink it down into a
tiny baby sized clown although it is an
alien form it has to abide by the rules
of the shapes it inhabits and with
Pennywise now we can do crap it mike
reaches down and pulls out its beating
heart then together the losers crush it
killing the evil entity for good this
moment shows that with mental strength
courage and unity the losers could go up
against the evil that it represents and
defeat it once and for all
it's death brings about the collapse of
Pennywise as lair as the evil beast
power fades away and the losers escape
just as a whole of new bald house falls
into the sinkhole below in a nod to how
in King's novel most of Derry itself was
destroyed after it was killed after the
trauma of the battle with it and Eddie's
death we get a bittersweet throwback to
the first movie when the five surviving
losers returned to the quarry and
Beverly jumps into the water followed by
the remaining four members of the club
this sad moment were we feel the loss of
both Eddie and Stanley was actually
foreshadowed back in the first film
where you can see a very similar shot of
Bev bill Ben and Mike and Ritchie
together in the water while Eddy and
Stanley are separated from the main
group next in the film we see the
consequences of defeating it for good or
even more far-reaching than the losers
might have imagined as they walk into
town Bev discovers that the deep scar on
the palm of our hand from the blood oath
they took as children has completely
disappeared as also happens in the book
her recurring nightmares of them all
dying if they left town before facing up
to Penny wiser now at an end and she's
proven the killer Klown wrong in his
taunts that her actions haven't changed
anything the disappearing scars fit in
nicely with what producer Barbara
muschietti has said about the film's
message that the past is a scar that
becomes leather at some point you have
to face it you won't be able to finish
your life if you don't get rid of that
trauma
the losers get courage through unity
Pennywise is a master of division he
basically wants to divide and conquer
their victory stems from remembering who
they were as kids and what they were
able to do when the scar was fresh Mike
also discovers later when he's looking
back at old newspaper cuttings that
reported his parents death in the fire
that the headlines have changed
originally the headline emphasized that
Mike's parents were drug addicts putting
blame on the victims rather than the
perpetrators of the atrocity after its
death though the headline has changed to
a more neutral report of two locals
dying in a house fire by destroying the
evil beneath it's as if the monsters
malignant influence on the town is
disappearing what's more this time even
after the losers leave Derry they no
longer forget what happened and their
memories remain intact when Mike talks
to Bill on the phone he wonders if it's
just because it's dead or if it's
because they now have more they want to
remember than forget before the film
ends we also discover that Stanley wrote
a letter to the losers before taking his
own life the letter explains how Stan
believed that what he did gave the
losers of best chance against his he
knew that he was too terrified to go
back to Derry Stan tried to repress his
memories of Pennywise in his life but
when Mike calls Stan tries to push back
with questions hoping to buy time but it
seems like he was always expecting this
moment and he simply says it's come back
hasn't it although all the losers were
terrorized by Pennywise as kids that
summer Stan perhaps suffered the worst
when he was almost eaten alive after it
separated him from the rest of the group
in the sewers Pennywise had his huge
razor-sharp jaws wrapped around Stan's
face and for him that memory was just
too terrifying and he couldn't face it
again always the most rational member of
the group in his letter Stan explains
that he made what he saw as the most
logical move and took himself off the
board by bringing the number of losers
alive down from 7 to 6 in his view they
could remain united which they wouldn't
have done if he hadn't returned to Derry
in this version of the story stan is
somewhat redeemed as we hear him say the
words I swear bill in his final moments
which in a way meant he fulfilled the
promise he made at the blood oath an
additional chapter to scene of young
dan giving his Bar Mitzvah speech also
stopped adult Ritchie from abandoning
the losers and Ritchie thanks Stan for
showing up for him in his time of need
Stan also acknowledges in this letter
that he's lived his whole life being
afraid and encourages everyone else not
to be this way and instead be proud of
who they are and who they want to be
this last point seems especially
pertinent to Richie who he Siri carving
a + e on the bridge an indication after
Eddie's death he'll no longer hide his
sexuality but the point also relates to
the other losers Mike finally decides to
leave Derry for a new life and Bev and
Ben are now together in a happy healthy
relationship with Bev's endless
nightmares replaced with beautiful
dreams for Bill defeating it for good
means he's now able to move on from the
ending of that screenplay he couldn't
finish and he's now actually writing the
first chapter of a new story in fact
that story we see on screen is actually
a passage from Stephen King's novel it
now if you'd like a chance to win some
of these awesome Pennywise Funko pops
make sure you have subscribed and leave
a comment with your thoughts about the
movie and click the gleam link to
register your details
the giveaway runs until the end of this
month and the winner will be contacted
via email if you enjoyed this and alike
is hugely appreciated and why not
unleash your inner movie lover and join
me every week discuss new movies
including the upcoming shining sequel
dr. sleep The Lion King giveaway winner
has been contacted so check your
notifications and send me an email so I
can send you the prize thanks for
watching and see you next time you PK
will be lovers